well one form of brexit is leaving the
single market and the customs union and
having a clean break with europe but
then there's going to be a lot of
economic dislocation but other people
people within the cabinet for example
are arguing for a much softer version
where we do abide by European rules and
regulations in certain areas but if we
do that we haven't taken back control we
just lost say over those rules and
regulations so really what I'm saying is
what's emerged in these past weeks
really through the divisions in kapner
the divisions in Parliament is that
there are different versions of brexit
so when we say braze it means briggsie
it actually means there's at least four
different types of brexit now being
debated in Parliament my point is we
can't say people in June 2016 voted for
this or that version of breaks it once
we know which version of breaks it the
government's going to negotiate and
offer us as a deal then it's right that
we have a final say on whether that deal
is one that we but are we getting closer
to that in that Teresa mates use a
phrase has been absolutely clear we are
leaving the customs union right so if we
do that then one big problem
intermediate arises what do you do about
Northern Ireland the hard border between
Northern Ireland and Republic of Ireland
I mean this I think everyone accepts the
government accepts would be a disaster
for relations between the two countries
and for the Good Friday Agreement so
what's the answer if you're not in some
form of customs union with the European
Union you're going to be with a hard
border and you're going to disrupt
significantly the trade between the
Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland
and that's just one example of the
difficulties that arise our financial
service sector enormous ly important to
the country we have a 90 billion pound
surplus with EU if we can't get access
into the Europe single market as we have
it at the moment where we're frankly the
predominant player of financial services
we're gonna lose jobs who can lose
investment we're gonna lose wealth from
the country well let's talk about the
other versions of taking back control of
it around and one coming from from your
party which is remaining in a customs
union which according to the shadow
foreign secretary will look pretty like
the customs union there's going to be a
big speech from the leader from Jeremy
Corbyn on Monday on this do you think
that is the correct
addition for labor to stay in the
customs you want it's a good evolution
of policy I obviously want us to go
further but I would welcome it but but
be under no doubt what that then means
if you're in a comprehensive customs
union between the UK and the European
Union you're not really going to be
striking free trade trade deals with
other countries and insofar as you are
in any form of customs union you're
going to make yourself much less
attractive to those other countries to
strike a trade deal so the point is that
everywhere you look the same dilemma
comes up if you we do over half our
trade with the EU if you want access
into that market you've got to keep
close to its rules in which case you
haven't taken back control indeed you've
actually lost the control you have
because you're no longer in the decision
making room on the other hand if you
want the freedom to strike out on your
own then the economic dislocation for
the country is going to be substantial
and that one of the things we do in this
report today is just go through not not
the reports from people here but all
around the world there's a consensus as
to what is happening with Britain
Britain at the moment and what will
happen if we go ahead with a clean break
brings it there's going to be
significant economic damage well I say
the consensus I mean there's economists
for brexit bought out a paper just the
other day said that Britain is going to
be better off right so the economists
Briggs's really interesting point
because it shows you exactly what the
problem is they're assuming that we have
literally frictionless trade with the
whole of Europe but we're still able to
strike all these deals on our own and
also we're getting rid of a whole lot of
the regulations that David Davis the
other day was saying we want actually
even higher standards than the rest of
Europe a lot of contradictions I get it
so how would you put that it's so
complicated back to the public again
they're not going to read your paper
then read it a lot of these other papers
they voted in June 2016 to leave the
European Union I'm sure people are
getting so so confused and what the
polls are telling us are they're getting
frustrated they're saying why haven't we
left already how would you test public
opinion again by what mode right
obviously the key point and a very good
point to make
so there's why we have Parliament so
Parliament's should be debating these
different issues and different versions
of what breaks it maybe my point is very
simple if it gets to the point which I
think increasingly it is possible we
will do where there isn't a consensus in
Parliament or a majority in parliament
for any particular type of breaks it in
other words once you try and put a
positive case for this Spriggs that as
opposed to these other breaks it's once
you do that and you find there's an
impasse at that point the sensible thing
since this originated this whole breaks
a business originated from the
referendum in June 2016 is to say it's
got to go back to the people to decide
do they want what is on offer from the
government now as opposed to what we
have now in the European Union and that
is a completely different choice from
June 2016 that was a choice do you want
to stay in Europe or not people said
okay we want to go but now we will have
the opportunity to pick a brexit from
the various versions so a referendum
with what three options on it well you
can decide that as when you come to it
exactly how you you phrase the
referendum I mean it could simply be
between the deal the government's going
to propose because they've got to
propose one in the end and remaining
inside the European Union my point is
very simple once you accept that even
people who voted leave have been voting
for different types of brexit then
there's got to be a way of resolving
which is the president we really want
what about sovereignty of parliament
though and there is common cause being
made by an assuming on the conservative
side that you could learn on the labor
side with an amendment to one of the
bills going through about staying in the
customs union do you think labour as a
whole should support that make common
cause with those on the conservative
side who think it's a bad idea to leave
the customs union absolutely of course
we should I mean this is much more
important than whatever party
affiliation this is the most important
decision in this country's taken since
World War two it's got enormous
implications for our future
just even around the Northern Ireland
question it's got an enormous
vacations and so you know it shouldn't
be a matter of Labor or conservative it
should be a matter of what do people
really think is in the interests of the
country and if if there is an amendment
that is going to unite some people in
the Conservative Party with the Labour
Party yeah we should be all for it and
let's talk about a Good Friday Agreement
because you mentioned it a few times
here of course you negotiated it do you
think it really is in danger now because
we've heard a for Northern Ireland
secretary amongst others saying it's
it's time is up I find it unbelievable
and distressing actually that you've got
apparently responsible people in
politics saying you know really doesn't
matter whether we keep the Good Friday
Agreement or not you know you you're
significantly younger than me but even
you will remember the times when you
know we would wake up every morning to
news from Northern Ireland of terrorist
acts of deaths and destruction the Good
Friday Agreement by and large has put
this to rest in the last 20 years you
can't put that at risk now if you had
one major part of the agreement was
precisely on the basis that the Republic
of Ireland and Northern Ireland would
have an open border so that there would
be an acceptance that even though the
Northern Ireland was staying inside the
UK nonetheless there was a recognition
of the politics of the island of Ireland
you break that up you're doing something
really a response do you think it's
significant and you know from those
negotiations just how important in
Northern Ireland need a NOLA violent
language it's just how important that is
that I noticed the other day the
Northern Ireland secretary started
referring to it is the Belfast agreement
which is the preferred form that
unionists tend to use it's known as the
Good Friday Agreement here and indeed in
nationalist sections of northern arm do
you think that's a sign that the dup
tail is wagging the Conservative dog
well it's a sign that as you say
languages is very divisive in this in
this area but when you call it the
Belfast agreement or the Good Friday
Agreement the fact is it gave us peace
for the first time in in a long long
period of time in Northern Ireland
and it gave us at least the opportunity
to forge a common future for the people
of Northern Ireland and if you put it at
risk it's it's obviously you know a sad
moment in a dangerous moment last
question about Jeremy Corbyn you were
elected the same year weren't you both
of you went into Parliament in 1983
there's been all these stories about
have been tapped up by cheques spies and
and the rest of it and the Defence
Secretary has said that some he's
betrayed his country what do you think
and look I might disagree mr. Jeremy
Corbyn are well known and well
documented and in my view there are
plenty of reasons for disagreeing with
his politics but this this story is
completely overblown I mean you know he
he may abused I don't agree with but I'm
not suggesting for a moment that he's a
spy or unpatriotic in the in his in his
views he just has a different point of
view from me so I think we're best to
return the political debate to something
well what about is I mean it's a
wet-behind-the-ears backbench Labour MP
in the 80s given what was going on mean
were you ever aware of any any
east-european types trying to tap you up
I can't say I was but I mean I look it's
it's to be to be frank about it I don't
suppose they were particularly
interested in what Labour backbench
and peas thought at a time when in any
event the Conservatives were in
government and looked like being in
government for a long time